what's up guys welcome back to the
quarter digital podcast episode insert
number here 153 says christian thank you
for keeping us
on point today we're talking about ai
pictures
why well it's because apparently
well joe here apparently
is an ai god no no
demigod
look we've been talking about all this
stuff over the last week stable
diffusion a dolly blah blah
but nico described you to me as like
you're the guy who who will stop the
actual devs from working on their models
if you have a tech support question
because that's how
deep you have gotten into this stuff i
mean i know nico's gotten in real deep
too i've seen some crazy stuff but yeah
yeah uh yeah i'm excited to talk about
this this is this is us uh how long do
we have 30 minutes to convince you to
get as much into it as we are and that
and i can see your face already i can
see it oh i'm into it okay no you're
never like you're not you need to you're
right okay obsessed with it i'm not i'm
not obsessed then it's mostly the
backlog of other things i gotta do first
before i can get obsessed right here
yeah
so you know this kind of brings me to
the like kind of first thing because
for some people
a present company included this is like
life-changing stuff right yeah and for
some people it's like i show them like
i'm like look you asked for like a blue
octopus like star wars ship and i made
it in like 30 seconds and they're like
oh cool
and like it's like a party trick um
so for you which one is it
uh yeah it's
it's
clip
a search engine kind of yeah it's yeah
yeah it's it's cool but it's also like
i mean i'm literally
working on this like d d show right now
so i'm like okay uh wouldn't it be funny
if there's like an oil painting of one
of these characters when they like talk
about it like we'll show it on screen so
i
can generate one yeah and that's nice i
i enjoy that element of it but even
still it's like still hard where it's
like
telling an ai to generate like a
detailed oh you you can only tell to do
one thing and it goes like all right
i'll take all this and make one thing
out of it you can't
you still can't go like hey it needs to
specifically like embody a few things
like yeah holding an object and this is
what he's wearing right and this is
where he is it's kind of like whoa whoa
whoa whoa we're just going to kind of
you know blend all that together and
like so i still have you know issues
with it but yeah back to the point no i
mean it's kind of good to hear it kind
of feel well it is kind of like clip art
in a way right now but that's all but
that's only because
you know people like are only impressed
with like what you can do with it well
that's what i think as we learned from
the ancient egyptians clip art is just
the precursor to a fully developed
writing system that oh yeah i don't know
if that's what they taught us but sure
that's what you know hieroglyphics
i had the same experience though i had
access to mid journey when it came out
and then i was like whoa i had some
people at my house like check this out
this is crazy and everyone's like all
right
me yeah right that's cool cool colors
yeah
my mistress uh and i made her like a
beautiful picture uh ai kind of sort of
generated took one of her images and
etcetera and she goes oh did you have
your mistress make our like
our anniversary photo come on yeah i'm
like oh
yes but this actually brings up a
question that i was going to say for
later let's just jump into it right now
all right this is this is gonna be the
hot take section of this podcast so
everybody heard about that one ai image
that won that state fair arcade yeah
there was that article yeah everybody
heard about that and it's one of those
things like i hear about that like it's
cool it's a fun novelty like news
article and i guess it's a little bit of
a sign of the times but it's like
it's such a
like misreporting of the news in a sense
like how
big what's actually happening is
happening like behind the scenes you
know it's just like it's a little story
that everybody gets and it's digestible
but it's not really haha someone won a
contest it's like by the way like
industry shifting tools are coming are
literally dropping faster than we can
keep up with them yeah over the past
like two months here but
what constitutes in your guys's opinion
what constitutes art when it comes to ai
art
because
yeah
you're getting real quick in there my
gosh yeah we're just gonna i need to
warm up man
here's my two cents please ai art is
only gonna matter when it's real time
like like dynamic so to speak like right
now it's fast to generate images but
like that's the idea of of like it only
for me becomes like a thing
where it's like here's like true like
purpose and value is when it's something
dynamic where it's like you're playing
ai dungeon like that game basically
brief explanation was
it's a like uh it's like a text
based game where you're entering in
prompts and it's giving you a story and
you're like you know you say oh pick up
the shovel or walk to the castle and it
gives you like a
a continuation of that storyline
um right now with like the ai art it's
like cool you can have an ai make a
mock-up or a concept for you but
the moment it's like this static
lifeless thing you know it's kind of
like cool you're just you know making
just cheap
you know it's like it's like the you
know it's like do you want an apple
branded iphone cable yeah or do you want
the 99-cent knock-off that's gonna break
you know and so it's like it turns art
into that in a sense where you're like
okay cool this is the amazon version of
art yeah you know but
but that being said it's like oh man if
you were playing a game and it's like
dude check this out here's a game here's
a game for you to play
here
was it up see uh so that was trained on
old pokemon footage right uh like
footage of of gameplay uh and it like
what the hell right
right yeah like it's super weird right
it's like a nightmare pokemon game it is
right it's like when you play pokemon
like when i played pokemon too much and
then i went to go to sleep and i was
still like playing pokemon like this is
what it is right it's a weird night oh
this is crazy it's like yeah it's like
just going it's
like it's okay
you could do that and then it like tries
to figure it out made by oh okay if you
want to check out this this crazy thing
that i'm seeing right now it's made by
it's called m a d e b y o l l dot i n
that's the site it's on yeah i don't
know i don't know i would just send this
link anyways we got a link maybe we'll
post it somewhere but okay so it's not
like actually a game technically but
it's it's like it doesn't know that it's
a real-time
ai like an actual model that's like
generating
unique images as you're like walking
around in it but yeah but even still
like okay here now we're bringing it to
life it's like in this world where you
can make anything based on these prompts
you can say anything it's like well
yeah it's like i feel like you wanna you
wanna experience it's it's fun when it's
it's like a surprise or it's like
happening but like when you can type in
anything you want
i don't know sometimes you're just kinda
like ah well you know there's something
about seeing ai images where it's like
they're not that exciting but there are
some that are exciting and i think it
just brings to mind like you have this
quote back when we were in college sam
where like
anything can be art but not
art isn't anything you know you have to
take something
and put intent and ideation into it to
turn it into art but anything can be art
once you take it and you turn it into
arts yeah basically but you can't just
like literally
everything isn't just art by default and
it's like same thing with like ai images
like you can type in a prompt and get a
cool picture you can spend an hour
refining your prompt and getting a
really cool picture but neither of those
necessarily make you
a great artist or a good artist like i'm
not trying to say like you can't be an
artist doing that but like
once you find like a really cool idea or
you've managed to deliver a cool concept
even if you're just typing a prompt and
getting a result that's when like the
art starts to be created where it's like
okay here's a thought here's an idea
here's a feeling i'm gonna make you feel
like that's when you start to step from
just prompting a picture and rolling the
dice and getting pretty anime girl
number 5263 from the machine listen the
waifus they are really important for
this you can tell where like everybody's
priorities are yeah yeah the anime girls
are honestly why we are making as much
progress as i am we are we really are i
mean it's true it is true pornography
and anime girls uh those two separate
things sometimes two same things
sometimes but
you know the number of programs that i
have called waifu on my computer
uh is three but it is higher than what i
would have imagined
god damn it but you know what's
interesting is i you know i think that
for such a long time we have back to you
like question about like the the state
fair being won by some some computer
right and people being like oh
since pixar came out you know it was
like oh to this day people just say oh
that's just computers
you both know that that's not the case
right right like it's uh basically like
a a puppetry inside of a a computer yeah
right uh who cares if it's the digital
or not so you're talking about prop
masters again yes right so like prompt
lords
prompt
queens they're
for us for such a long time we've
defined being human for many people
being human as
like making art art is the thing that
distinguishes us and like when when uh
an elephant grabs a paintbrush and
starts making whatever's
that's a big deal and you know you have
all of these people being like that's
not real art by the way that's just like
it's just doing that
he's pulling on the tail and makes the
elephant do it right there's no like
there's copy bars don't care about
sonnets right like then is it maybe it's
levels of art because you know it's like
because once again like
at face value here what is the artistry
it's like
knowing when to type unreal engine 5.
you know that's like the gag well that's
that's the other thing that's that's the
technician that's the craftsman because
there's always the difference between
the artists and the craftsmen well very
much the overlap okay but what is
technique and the other one is the
actual idea have you seen my kid could
paint that that documentary about like
this four-year-old girl six-year-old
whatever however old she was and she did
drip paintings
um and it's the whole mess of like some
people being like she's a prodigy and
some people be like she's dripping some
stuff onto a canvas she's not a real
artist she's just the kid well i guess
that's the thing it's like are there are
there barriers or levels of artistry you
know are those because i still think
think it's like because you can just
type a simple sentence or a string of
words and and then that's when that's
that's how you create the art it's like
yeah
like
you know where like where is the value
of craft what is a poem what is a poem
about a string of words
you don't even have to i i
purposely was trying to be like how
little do i have to give mid journey
which has a very strong uh if we're
going to get a different ais right
majority like just makes art for you
like or pretty things for you yeah who
knows if it's hard right i don't know uh
but i went to i figured out a way where
i could give an empty character that i
didn't know was an empty character uh
but i gave it an empty character and it
made like some some beautiful portrait
of some woman right uh and i'm like
thanks but like so it was that art was
that not i don't know it can be like i
think as with everything it can be it's
just it's about the idea you know and i
you know obviously like i'm not the
freaking king of like art rules here
it's just my opinion i love uh guys like
have you heard of marcel duchamp and his
uh his ready-made dadaism right that is
him right like it literally uh he signed
a toilet and then was like i'm this is
my art yeah and like that's great that's
i think it's one yeah
yeah i guess that maybe is that is that
well that's where the line came from sam
when you were learning that in art yeah
yeah anything could be art right but art
isn't anything like it took him signing
that and putting on that and making a
a point about art for people like okay
interesting you're getting into my mind
here you're making me think about this
like that's where the art comes in
mm-hmm you know yeah but i guess it's
like what is the what's the
sorry this is it's just such a
confounding
concept to even consider because yeah i
guess it's like when anyone can do it so
to speak where it's like when it takes
like there's no barrier to entry i guess
there's no barrier to entry of picking
up a paintbrush or a crayon too there is
there's years of of trying to learn how
to like mix the colors or or whatever
right well i guess it takes a few days
or hours or to figure out some nice
prompt strings i guess
you know
yeah but just putting time into
something does not make it art you know
right right like the ready-mades yeah
yeah it's like it's all about thought
process and decision-making and that's
what creates the art but at the same
time
you know when it's
when when when like
that's like saying hey uh like i know
let's say nico he's great with the
pencil he can draw some stuff and i'm
like hey nico can you draw me great with
the pencil can you make some sweet anime
art for me and he goes like uh like this
i'm like ah more moody lighting please
can you make it more like unreal engines
and then makes it an art style and then
i take it i'm like look what i made
you know wow i see i see okay so you're
talking about art oh okay i made art i
see i came up with the idea of i wanted
it to be this anime thing i wanted him
to draw with pencil
you know unreal engine unreal
but like i made art now and it's like
that's what it feels like with the ai
stuff because that's basically what the
process is there was a guy who painted a
a campbell's can of suit so yeah he used
to do that right he had his little uh
a little thing right yeah yeah he did
that he was like that's mine uh and
people were like but you have like a
bunch of people working for he's like i
don't know i don't care that's mine
right so is that his
uh
i don't shoot i don't know i don't know
i don't know either i don't know i don't
know i know but even still it's just
kind of like it feels it feels weird
though because it's once again
here's the other crazy thing yeah so
yeah you make a really cool let's say
you're like all right here is my crazy
picture that i generated using ai yeah
using stable diffusion and you know what
it's a crazy idea it's a cool
juxtaposition i got a great composition
i didn't just find a good prompt i have
an interesting idea and you know show me
a picture like that's art like anyways i
can type in the exact same prompt the
seed and make the same picture meaning
you don't own that picture sure you just
triggered it are we talking about nfts
or are we talking about yeah art in
general like yeah concepts you know it's
like did you make that picture or did
you just find the door to open ai tools
are great and all but there's one thing
that they can't do and that's keep your
feet comfortable stylish and warm all
day long as we enter fall and winter
here but courtesy of today's sponsor
bessie that's exactly what you'll be
able to do with a pair of vessies on
your feetsies now vestis are 100
waterproof and snow proof meaning that
they're great for the diverse weather
conditions you get in fall and winter
they can go through slush snow sleet
rain they're also built with a patented
dimetex material meaning that they're
going to keep your feet warm in the
winter and cool in the summer and with
their nice comfortable anti-microbial
souls your feet are going to be smelling
good all year long they're comfortable
you can flex them any way you want it's
like putting a sock on your feet but in
the form of a comfortable waterproof
shoe and if that's not enough vessies
use less waste during the knitting
process and they have no animal
by-products meaning that they are 100
vegan and good to go for your
computer-minded consciousness so if
you're interested in getting rid of
those winter boots and putting something
on your feet that's comfortable stylish
consider getting a pair of vessies today
if you go to vessie.com corridor cast
you'll get 25
off every pair of adult bessie shoes
that you buy that's 25 off by going to
bessie.com corridorcast or just click
the link in the description below huge
thanks to them for always sponsoring
everything we do over here at corridor
and uh let's get back to that
conversation
and like i can just go and open the same
door on the ai and get the same picture
you know right now here's here's what's
interesting right
uh there are ways of modeling like if
we're getting a little bit more
technical ways of like creating a graph
of what everyone has made right so far
and people have made some weird stuff
right like everything from homer simpson
in the godfather all the way to like the
anime girls to like yeah you know oh
there's a the weird stuff thing when
starts at anime girls and goes from
there oh yeah right
and like
the amount of prompts that um i saw with
people trying to make like women wearing
quote-unquote invisible dresses
anyway or dresses made of air because
they were trying to get around like the
filter the filters
people are really smart man about this
kind of stuff the people are gonna get
their porn
the amount of terms that i've learned
for for sexual positions in any
anyway
you can take all this stuff that people
have made and put it into a big graph
and then you can see that it's got like
vendrickalls going everywhere right so
then you might be able to just move like
a little thing around and be like what's
over here well no one's made two or only
two or three things were made over here
and most of the time it's going to be
like
whatever the hell right like it's a
weird mashup of images and shapes yeah
but this basically the library of babel
right yeah like where
any image
is possible to be created right like a
512 by 512
if you can fit it into that
you can create it with with stable right
or with some of this ai as you were
saying so you start moving around there
like
over here no one's ever done this yet
because there's no dots there there's
nothing in the graph but let's go see
what's there yeah and now you can
immediately go like here's the various
different art genres that haven't been
invented yet we can see them all
immediately yes
exactly i'll just go look at all of them
right now it's like wow so now yeah
that's that would that's going to be
really hard right but
you you're the one who explored it you
know you're the one who found it
as would be like you with a pencil or
with a brush or whatever you know with a
camera with a pen with a with a brain
like what's the analogy there because is
it like outer space at this point
you know it's like
i don't know in space buddy it's late in
space cyberspace is done we live in
latent space now man this is web web
17.0 man yep um yeah i mean we skipped
four through 16 ai told us to skip four
through 16 we didn't want to touch it
let's talk about that real quick just
how fast things change because that's
what we were saying in our last podcast
like wow things are going so fast and
they just got faster like literally a
week ago we dropped a podcast talking
about stable diffusion how great it was
i don't even remember a week yeah man i
haven't slept and god knows how long
because
my wife wakes up it's four o'clock in
the morning and i'm like okay just a
second i just need to keep training i
just need to keep training that's just
i've been trying for i trained the thing
for a week and a half on on it looking
like me i'll show you some of the images
if when you're when you're ready because
it was very very ugly uh yeah
now's a great time you should show sam
you know what i will um so while you
pull up your picture i'll just explain
real quick so hey you got this big model
you can type in anything you get a
picture you're like okay well i'm going
to type in me as in like i'm going gonna
type my name in and like nothing comes
up you're like that's weird it's like
yeah because it doesn't know who you are
you're not famous enough to be yeah
cataloged thousands of times on the
internet as in pictures or like me uh i
am famous enough uh
clearly
you are also famous enough i would
imagine to be on this thing but for me
it thinks the the way that it breaks up
the text is uh joe and then pen and nah
so usually i get like some old guy named
joe
holding a pen in the ancient city of now
[Laughter]
and i can't
so i have to train it myself you know
yeah unfortunately this is a friend of
mine um right and
there are if you look at his uh
wikipedia page right there's one image
there where he's kind of sort of
squinting right and he's a very good
looking fella um i don't have his
permission to show this so i'll just
show it to you guys but you can see that
all of the images that it made were the
exact squinty face and it's just like
uncanny valley again deep deep in the
uncanny valley because holy crap that is
weird right um so i decided to give it
try to trick it into thinking that i'm a
very good looking fella right um by only
giving it like the professional
headshots that are were very carefully
curated right uh
and
oh eventually i was like no i'm gonna
give it all right like me wearing a
space helmet me wearing uh all types of
glasses me and shadow
and and yeah like it made
uh something
um
it's like a tim and eric character
yeah if you can see that right like it's
it's
i love how much he's like
at least i know that he is happy
wow he's like his enlightened version of
you right yeah um
so
yeah so so not wonderful um
clearly a guy who also uh needs a lot of
dental work and rogaine
wow that's weird right the ai's just
itching to give you that unibrow
i've been working hard to get rid of it
so there was also one image of me uh
that was like my arms spread spread out
like this and i was like doing whatever
the face that mystery tarman used to
make right but the
my fingers got caught in the like lens
distortion right the barrel lens
distortion
so i thought that that's what my fingers
looked like
so
it only created
images of me
like this sausage fingers
big giant
giants
right and then the
everyone was like okay that's hilarious
however just ask for like a close-up but
then of course you gave me a close-up of
like doing this which is like the
sausage
do you look like you're from rrr or
something right or uh uh everything
everywhere once yeah
and also like
i i didn't realize like how much like
every tiny little image would make sense
so i gave it pictures of me
that were kind of like this and i try to
crop my face out but my wife is in there
so very much it was like oh no is this
what you are
yeah
there's always this like a second face
always against
i think this is are you are you this is
it right yeah um but then eventually it
started getting a little closer
ooh yeah that indiana jones version of
you is very nice like there's that's
like old version of me that's good yeah
right yeah like a charcoal drawing of me
yeah um i can share with these with you
after and then some more indiana jones
this is training like for days and days
and days on this by this point this is
this is like three days of training yeah
um this is uh joe penna speaks aramaic
yeah and that one looks really sacrilege
i believe uh this is illegal in some
countries
it's illegal in some countries
but like even little things where like i
used an auto face cropper i'm sure you
guys have used for the deep fake stuff
but i thought that like that's what i
was you know
like a half and half image of me that's
so odd uh so
hours and days of training eventually it
got to like a point where i could i
could call it kind of like that's likely
somewhat me but guess what on my drive
down
for the last 15 minutes i've been trying
to figure out how to park here
this guy figured out how to do it in 15
minutes
and he has some images that are like
really freaking incredible that really
look like him
what's the process called so
so i'm doing something so google made
this thing
this thing they have this idea called
dream booth right so you have everything
in latent space and everybody likes to
use the term dreaming for when you're
having a computer invent these images
which is honestly
pretty apt because i feel like it's kind
of the same thing that's happening in
your brain when you're dreaming right
and google's like well how do you put
yourself in the dreams everybody's going
to want to do that right you want to
generate a picture of dog well you're
going to want to generate a picture of
your dog so how do you put your dog into
the system and say this idea called
dreambooth
and the thing is it was implemented with
google's imogen which is like their
version of dolly to stabilization
mid-journey and google's like no
no one can use it
[Laughter]
no this is ours
so some person's like well what if i
just take their principles and use the
stable diffusion engine instead
and
joe sent me the link he's like hey check
this out somebody has this new idea and
i'm like i'm gonna make it work and i
spent the past four hours figuring out
which computer had enough vram to run it
turns out only one of our machines shout
out to puget for setting us up with an
ai machine with an a6000 because i
needed 38 gigs of vram
and it made a perfect me
uh just straight up i don't i skipped
you know unfortunately i'm i'm a little
sad i didn't get to enjoy all the wonky
steps there
listen if you want some wonky pictures
of you i will purposefully
but i'm gonna
wow this is a great time to check out
the
version on youtube or on corridor
digital.com
that looks good i don't know don't you
guys make less money on the video
version no no do not do not we're going
to spend the next 30 minutes describing
exactly what the image is like do not go
to that i'll read off a grid of the
pixel colors and you can just type those
in pixel by pixel to get the image
so look at that like like literally
yesterday i i was trying i'm still
training it's still going
and today it's it's already doing that
in 15 minutes yes and this came out two
weeks ago yeah because the thing that
was it two weeks ago that was with oh
god it was two weeks ago yeah it was two
weeks ago wow it's like two and a half
weeks ago now you're right but that's
the half makes a difference
the crazy thing is like so the reason
like
i think the reason why well actually let
me phrase this joe as our guest tell me
why are you so hyped about being able to
add things to the model
when you can add your face why have you
spent a week and a half trying to
get yourself into this model so you can
type give me a picture of joe pano at
the top hat drawn by greg grotkowski
trendy on art station
margot robbie wearing an air dress
[Laughter]
my god the amount of words that i know
now because
okay um what's the obsession man the
obsession man is because
because i have been able to get two jobs
in the last month
uh like film making jobs that are as of
yet
unannounced because of this technology
right
because
some people in my industry uh in our
industry in any industry they have a
hard time imagining it that's actually
there's a disease not disease there's a
there's a
a condition called a fantasia for some
people cannot like when you when i say
uh you know picture a red apple right
close your eyes uh
i don't even have to close my eyes oh
there you go so you know yeah
you didn't even even gotta do it right
some people can't do it some people are
like okay
yeah no i understand what a red apple
looks like but i can't picture it it's
not on a table it's not it doesn't have
its friends you know um so for those
people uh who somehow just all for some
reason are producers in hollywood
uh
yeah you know they need to see
they need to see margot robbie
preferably wearing some sort of dress
not made of air you know or they need to
see oscar isaac where they need to see
like a concept art and
i can't draw
and i can only hire a concept artist to
fix up the images that i like make but
also it's amazing that i can work with a
concept artist to be like hey i spent
like eight days just like generating
generating generating and it took me
forever but like these are the three
images that i got that i would not have
been able to search for them
you know um
can you take these and then like do your
human thing to it uh all right um so i
have like i can do things like hey add
like uh here's a monster that i'm making
add like a fishtail to this thing uh or
add this or add that so that we don't
end up with the same like looking
monster that we've seen in like all the
things as a as of late you know sure
so it will help me with my job uh in
every step like i can literally be like
oh uh this prop designer made like a
cool looking gun picture picture picture
picture picture you guys have done
something similar with photogrammetry
right and stuff like that uh but then i
can just tell tell uh stable effusion be
like hey uh can you make uh
can you make my character doing that you
know i can make a comic book i can do
anything like i can do all these things
that i'm like me george clooney yes in
an army outfit holding my laser gun
holding my laser my laser gun holding
wearing my
outfit that i had my my
my a person who designs outfits and i
literally forgot because i have not
slept for two and a half i see what
you're saying
that's kind of cool though yeah so it's
like the idea of like look we have some
things that we want yeah but we don't
have everything and so we're trying to
like okay you have like the 20 where
it's like okay we want to work with this
actor
we know it's supposed to be like the
setting and yeah maybe maybe we have
like a special prop we have designed
yeah but it's the idea of basically
keeping that consistent between images
like just
like i'm assuming if you can train it on
a face you could train it on an object
too you can that's what it's made for
yeah style you can train it on an
emotion you can train it so so when you
when you tell it that thing that key
word that you've trained it on it goes
like okay cool that like cool like
red glossy laser gun that you want to
have in this thing cool i know what that
looks like yeah and now suddenly tom
cruise has his little laser gun yeah in
all the photos and but now he's now he's
blue or now he's in space so now he's
driving a car yeah but he's always
holding that little lazy gun yes
or like has like a hat or you know or
like that's interesting
uh so
so this is where we can get interesting
with it right like if i'm a comic artist
like i'm working with a on a on a
graphic novel right now with a real
artist then etcetera
and
i'm not like i can't draw right like a
person who can actually like put the pen
to paper right and those digital
paintings and stuff and i'm like hey do
you mind if i teach the ai how to draw
your stuff and they were like i need you
to explain like every part of what that
would entail please before i say yes and
i'm like i can take every image you've
ever drawn
and give it to this thing right and then
it i can say in the style of
asterisk this this person right and then
i can say i can ask for things like hey
uh
you know podcast the cool dudes in the
style of this this article you know um
that's a really crazy idea of like just
saying hey you know what i i want to get
like
a character artist and give me a like
like the uh like the style sheet or
whatever it is
yeah of like here's the character and
like a couple angles of them yeah and
you then you train that and then you're
like yeah
i'm gonna make my own comic now with
this consistent character throughout all
of them quite literally nico was talking
about that up upstairs right so like wow
i i'm not a comic book artist but you're
not a comic race but that's gonna make
for some great fan fiction
you're like yo i like berserk and i'm
like i'm just gonna scan all this stuff
from this comic and then make my own
sequel handsome
chiseled
berserk i don't know what his name is
whatever hannah i don't know i just
thought of that because i was like
because the artist who wrote it
has been griffin's been making a bunch
of art son of a dungeon
i actually i do wonder how griffin feels
about all this and we should ask him
because
literally the ai machine is literally
behind him
behind griffin's back yes
right now they're using ai stuff for all
the art but it's basically more like
stylistic backdrops and stuff like that
where it's like it's an element there
but it's not like for the purpose of
recreating something specific yeah but
imagine i took all griffin's drawings
i trained i fine-tuned the model i add
them into the model like with an
identifier griffin thorn art or
something like that
and then i say like okay well we got you
know he drew some mind flares he drew
some people to town let's say i go like
well okay we have uh this part we come
across uh a giant worm it's like okay
well
uh giant uh monster worm
yeah scaly
uh griffin thorn art style and then this
is where you can get a little hairy
though yeah right
do you know how this was done how like
this whole thing was was like created
yeah yeah right there
like how it like it just strained it on
common crawl which was the the web
like the interweb right uh everything so
you you can say like hey in the style of
uh yeah simon stalin
i'm familiar with that concept of right
yeah so like is that okay
to to say that yeah
it's okay well it's okay and it's not in
the sense that like
it's no different than if you were to
make a painting and if you just straight
up rip off simon stalin hog yeah even if
you'd paint it yourself and you didn't
use an ai to do it you're still ripping
off simon stalin hogg right so it's like
you gotta bring something to the table
otherwise it's just a rip-off it doesn't
matter if an ai does it or if you do it
if you're going to like present it as
your art and it's just a straight-up
copy
then it's like it you know we don't need
the ai future to define whether or not
that's cool or not because we've already
defined it it's like i mean it's no
different than it's no different than
just like how normal or even you know
like already operates where people make
styles and if they become popular then
it becomes oversaturated and then either
the artist moves on from that style or
uh or maybe everyone's just like the
copycats aren't as good so i don't know
yeah yeah well but it blends it up now
in this situation yeah you can mash it
up and end also like it is weirder
because it's not just like a here's
someone else copying someone's style but
it's like no it's like literally
the style
is exactly copied right which is kind of
weird but like as you were saying with
griffin too in his heart it's like the
thing is like that art that he's doing
is also kind of based already on another
artist's style i forget
because like that was that was one of
the inspirations so it's like that's the
case for every human yeah who's who's
art isn't yeah yeah like it's all based
on people even uh has
based on other stuff yeah right like um
so that's the question right like it
one thing i disagree about there are
things i disagree about and things i
agree about with simon right uh he talks
specifically he's like i think that uh
ai can't create new stuff right it's
just like derivative kind of work and if
you're somebody who makes your money
like just turning out derivative kind of
stuff yeah you're from the you're in
trouble but it will never get to my
level um right or he he was he didn't
mean it like me because i'm so great he
mean like he means like the the thought
process of a human being right like it
can't like make something that's
meaningful uh because it can only copy
stuff and i'm like
i think he has a misunderstanding of
like what it is literally the library of
babel like the thing where like if you
have enough monkeys with typewriters
it'll type shakespeare but it'll also
type anything that's typeable right um
like it will learn him better and it
will get better than him and better than
any human being alive and that's kind of
the that's why i'm not freaking out
because i know that outside of maybe
like what uh
athletes
there's not a job on earth that isn't
threatened by ai well the funny thing is
i feel like a lot of people think about
that as this as like the movie archetype
of like you got your matrix robots and
you got your human beings and we're
fighting our wars right yeah
when in reality these are just tools no
it's just could be humans fighting
humans
yeah it's like at the end of the day
humans with ai versus humans without ai
yeah
yeah who's gonna win
yeah that's where it actually happens
actually at the end of the day it's
this is a case where the artist
can draw
five or six or ten pictures it's in the
style of the project they're working on
the artist can train it into the model
and now that artist as a singular human
being can output a thousand drawings in
a day rather than one right it's still
that artists doing their work it's still
that artist using the tool it's still
that artist that needs to come up with
the story create the characters come
with the ideas etc but this is a tool
it's no different than a typewriter
versus a pen and paper a typewriter lets
you write faster and more clear and now
now you're on a computer now you can
duplicate your paper 100 times you can
save versions of it
but it's still just a tool that's making
your creativity faster and this ai is no
different it just so happens that this
tool
is about a thousand times better than
the tools that were out a year ago
it's like the amount of advancement that
happened in one you kept putting dog
faces on everything remember like the
mona lisa she's a dog and like her dress
is dog and everything is dog because
there were so many dog pictures right
yeah um
it is it is a big deal right like that
that we can do this but like i think
that
there is not a single
uh
a question that we have out there the ai
is not going to fix because it's
they're better than us right they're
better than humans like they're now
better artists um
if you do the right thing you know like
if
sorry when's this podcast coming out
because it's like in a week okay so yeah
they're now better artists
yeah
and uh you know but like they're gonna
they're gonna be better drivers they
kind of already are better drivers than
that yeah they're gonna be better
doctors than us because they're we're
going to train biases out of it you know
there's there's studies that show that
like
really well-respected doctors are like
okay how much is this person feeling
pain and they they're like they give
them uh a number right and how much is
that that person feeling pain if and if
that person's black they always rate
lower so you know they can handle it
right that's that's biased right we can
train that out of ai systems or we can
at least see it because right now it's
true it's just
a computer that's like i want to be just
like you daddy
and it's doing it has all of the biases
and we're trying to figure out ways like
where it's like okay so when you ask for
doctor in the ai it just makes like a
bunch of white dudes
so like let's just throw in like
secretly words like black female in
there every once in a while but then
it makes like black
like female
sumo wrestlers yeah and like that's is
that okay no i mean that i had that
issue i was trying to create a character
for a script i'm writing
and
the character
right now is basically based off jordan
coleman right yeah and so trying to get
a african-american woman that looks like
jordan coleman was really difficult
because you just type in a woman you get
a white woman if you type in
african-american woman that becomes very
very emphasized to the point where it's
like
it's all about ethnicity like it's
almost a character yeah it's not quite a
character but it's like it's very like
focused on the you know whatever
physical features to find that ethnicity
that you type in so you'd like how do
you get in between that and like how do
you deal with that it's like well
there's not really a way to do it unless
you kind of start tricking the system
and the method i use was to use a
painter
that
mainly painted people of color so at no
point do i ever mention the person's
ethnicity i just use that artist as one
of the artists yeah i have the style
that's what i was thinking which is like
yeah the bias is like in the training of
like all right what is defined as like
the the noun here yeah you know like
yeah that's that's crazy yeah but kerry
washington does not look good as good as
shirley's throne you know uh in in these
models i know because i've tried both
you know i had a lookbook that i was
working on for a popular entertainment
television for er
you know
i can't i can't say it it's it's
but um
you know
i couldn't i couldn't make any black
people uh
look as good as the white people i could
make them right but like
you saw like the friend of mine uh he's
black and it only has one single image
of him right so it makes that same
squinchy face that he was making because
it was he was in the sun in everything
so like that's why i think that that
training is important i can throw all
those pretty pictures of him
into it and then it can make it can help
me
like put a black character into a role
that you know a producer was imagining
for a white dude you know uh and then
all of a sudden that i can sell them on
that a little bit better yeah yeah
that's weird it's a communication tool
it's letting you
like here's my vision and try to ride it
and try to draw with my neanderthal
hands
or i can use modern technology to
invent this image in minutes if less if
not less so i can show it to you like
this is my vision yeah and the person's
like oh i get it
first came out remember photoshop first
came out and
um all these nature photographers were
getting into trouble because
especially ones that like got into
helicopters and took pictures of like
massive herds of animals there was one
guy specifically that had these amazing
images that looked like herds of animals
like they look like rivers right but
then it came out he was using evil evil
photoshop and like removing the
stragglers and filling in the holes in
the middle to make it look like a river
uh and people were like this is this is
not okay like you're you're you're
messing with nature and you're messing
with the reality and like this kind of
stuff shouldn't show up in national
geographic
nowadays i think that nobody cares and i
think we photoshop out the handlers of
the lions all the time
right like
i think eventually it's gonna change and
i think and
will you please stay up until three
o'clock in the morning with nico and i
to try to figure some of this stuff out
all i know is that nvidia needs to start
throwing more vram in their gpus
everybody needs more vram everyone right
now gpu is gonna be back i thought the
crypto
total gang definitely did not hold to
their gpus no they didn't yeah it turns
out turns out when you don't spell hold
correctly no one knows what it means
[Applause]
oh three months in i'm out
yeah like biology right like um
satellite imagery physics simulations
you guys have done those uh like there
are people that are there's a whole
company that's like generating
uh uh censor
stuff for like uh but my dad he's i was
like he's like how have you been i'm
like good dad like the last two and a
half weeks i've just been doing this ai
stuff he's like what do you mean like i
work on ai and i'm like i didn't know
this i thought you were motion control
engineer tell me everything like
have you gotten into textual inversion
with like pie torch or or do you think
that that is something that i shouldn't
that
i should use a tpu right instead of a
gpu
so like literally what he's working on
is like these diesel gross diesel
engines like removing emissions like
lessening their emissions in in like
knowing like oh this this isn't running
the way it should i doubt that in like
five years or 10 years you're gonna be
able to buy
a refrigerator
without like ai in it because of like oh
it knows when like you're gonna put like
new groceries into it you know and like
learns you
like movies are gonna like follow your
watch if they're getting boring
like you're getting bored with this
podcast we're trying to like just
proselytize you like no like if they're
getting boring they're gonna like
they're going to like throw something
scary at you they're going to create
something new games like you're going to
be able to start playing a game and it's
going to be kind of what spore was meant
to be
you know where like you've seen this
into a world this is the part i don't
like about it though that's the like
this is this is like my that's what you
asked for dystopian version yeah
yeah but like i don't want it to be
something that's praying off of like
like
like i don't want to have it feel like
it it's it's preying on me so to speak i
want it to feel like that it's like it's
cool when it's like i was like when i
was talking about the dynamic thing
earlier
it's like it's cool when it's dynamic
based off of
like decision making and like your like
your your input so to speak but the
thing is is like the way you describe it
there that's like the google facebook
like dystopian model of like okay
um
sweet uh it's like hello sam can i
entertain you today and i'm like yeah no
don't entertain oh god damn it this is
sweet it's entertaining
it's it starts playing dope [ __ ] i'm
like [ __ ] all right
i'll watch this for like 20 minutes yeah
and then it's like are you going it's
like sam i can continue to entertain you
i'm like no you're doing a really good
ai voice
um
okay
i'm sorry sam i'm sorry sam oh that's so
much yes
perhaps you'd like to listen to some
music instead in fact i've invented a
new genre yes it was a genre that works
a new genre that's right in between your
listening habits yeah
i want britney spears toxic with
tchaikovsky like whatever that is here's
the thing it's like it's already figured
it out before you say it yes it's like i
know that that's what you want yeah like
yeah you're like we're gonna get bored
with the jogging or something and you're
like i want some good stuff to listen to
and it's just like we know yeah like
each time you run you run for 15 minutes
and then if there's like if you sit
there for more than 10 seconds scrolling
through it means you can't find a cool
album to listen to next therefore it
generates brand new custom music yeah
it's like and that's it's like yeah that
feels just so gross why right like it is
i mean that's happening right now with
tick-tock you're scrolling do you do
tick-tock
no oh he doesn't do tick-tock no no no
he doesn't have an apple watch he
doesn't do tick-tock you don't even have
siri turned on on your phone i don't
[Laughter]
hey siri does your phone turn on it does
but it's only on usually
an accident
like but like you know i understand that
it's just the thing is like that's not
like
that's not the [ __ ] i want someone to
figure out ahead of time for yeah yeah
you know what i'm saying like me you
figure it out yourself like i don't want
someone making ad money based off of
that kind of habit like i want someone
to [ __ ] like
wash my truck
you know i want someone to like tell me
that hey
yo like your shit's about to like you're
some some pipes about to burst in your
head like that's the stuff like i i want
a computer to figure out for me before
it happens but i don't want it to be
like oh we've crafted the most addictive
like content experience
for you yeah and like because that's
that's not cool that just pulls you away
from
like your own inherent motivations
you know uh that's valid yeah and so
that that's so when you train an ai
model to make sure that you're feeling a
sense of fulfillment and not being
exploited when i was gonna say right
like the ai is gonna make you feel like
you got there you know
and yeah that's the thing
so it's the i asked this question to
people who i have this conversation with
often um
if you could
take a pill
right and it puts you to sleep but then
you wake up and then you uh go on a trip
to
cairo there's a tim and eric sketch
about that is there yeah it's like this
medicine that you like
it's jeff goldblum's thing like oh i it
would be just like like i'm you know
famous and uh there's a lifetime
achievement ceremony on friday but it's
monday and i can't wait mm-hmm i can't
wait i hear you're saying
that he's good with the voices
so you take this pill and then you
fall asleep and you wake up in five days
[Laughter]
sorry
you're reminding me of that no that's
exactly what i mean like if you go on a
trip to cairo right it feels super real
right
and then you get back home you you fly
home and and then that's it right like
you you wake up and all right thank you
for your uh i remember as a reminder it
is still tuesday uh but like last
tuesday right because that was all like
an ar
vr whatever our experience right that
just makes me feel sad okay so it makes
you feel sad how does it make you feel
uh bewildered people okay yes i i i
don't know where i am okay i don't know
it's a positive bewilderment it's like
stars in my eyes like ooh i think i'd do
it like there's that place at the mall
here that you can like put your goggles
on and ride dragons and stuff right and
it kind of sort of made me sick but it
was super interesting um
i mean i love that kind of stuff yeah i
like that stuff and this is kind of like
so someone said no but i wouldn't
experience like
you know like uh getting on a bus and
the the tire blows out and you know you
have to stay with like a very kind
stranger that night that takes you in
and they didn't you didn't speak their
language you they didn't speak your
language and like that's what i'd be
missing and i'm like but that's what the
ai could it could do that you could do
that
and it would know that that's what
you're missing
you know like eventually yeah but then
but someone some guy's got to train it
to have no biases and then like where's
the strife
oh no you want strife just throw the
strife up you know like it's yeah it's
like your trip to cairo strike weights
uh 0.9
i love cairo in the 1970s i just went
there
and you have to check out europa it's
really beautiful uh do the one without
the aliens though like you know
the racist aliens by the way you saw you
saw the
the stable diffusion renderer for
blender we just start modeling your
scene
and then it uses the ai image generator
to be like oh you got like a pot and
it's like some rough geometric flowers
okay you don't have to render it we
already know what things look like so
we'll just give you what it would look
like if you rendered it nicely with good
materials and actually like good flowers
yeah yes that's gonna be i mean you do
that now with just image the image right
yeah it's it's amazing
the way you used to have to do it is to
like
there's a light here you shoot a
thousand light rays into the why am i
explaining this to you guys you know
this better than i do uh but for the
people out there who just learned it uh
like me uh you used to have to like
shoot a bunch of
rays called retracing right like i think
i don't know
we're still retracing but yeah you said
yeah so so now it doesn't you just say
like there's a light here uh and it's
like
there you go it's just like this oh yeah
you've
human beings have been doing ray tracing
for the past like 30 years and there's a
bunch of examples online so i get the
general just hit so if there's a light
here it would probably look like this if
you retrace it and it just gives it to
you like it gives you its guess right
like a little clip
like paper clip comes up it's like hey
it looks like you're trying to model a
pot
you know
would you like some help modeling a
little yeah do you want to see what it
looks like if you rendered it nicely
it's like yeah it also modeled it nicely
hey don't do that with the eyes do this
i know what i was looking like in your
house
you mind if i make a draw the rest of
the owl for you you need it people are
doing that with their kids drawings now
you know like they're taking their kids
whatever drawings and then making like
amazing like perfectly perfect like
dragons out of it you know and and the
kid just drew like
um yeah and yeah like it's i hear you
though i hear you because if my
seven-year-old or eight-year-old now i'm
sorry i'm sorry jonah you're eight you
just had your birthday uh if my
eight-year-old
draws like on an ipad or whatever and
all of a sudden it like morphs into a
perfect dragon that he was trying to
draw
is that
is that taking something away from his
experience you know from him learning
the like the strife that you talk about
of learning how to like that's not how i
move my hand if i want a dragon you know
well but see that's the thing like the
appreciation of like i don't download
desktop art because of like a cool the
cool prompt that someone typed in to
make it i'm like i look at him like this
is just
beautiful to look at and like i
appreciate the person for
learning how to do this and like being
able to you know
render it so brilliantly whether it's
through 3d or
with something like that and so like
that there's an appreciation there it's
like
the image
isn't what's famous for me i'm not like
dude that picture oh yeah it's like no
like i i i appreciate the artist i
appreciate the person
behind it and it's usually because it's
like all right well
it's it's this thing where what if it's
a world where all art is so brilliant
and saturated and just like looks
incredible and
is so eye-catching and vibrant and
intricately detailed and stuff like that
to the point where
you know it kind of it kind of makes it
so that anyone who knows how to do that
it's just feels like another drop in the
bucket yeah you know it's weird so then
maybe we'll get some dataism again right
you get some
you get some things that look like
toilet yeah right and
i think that there will be a pendulum
swing the other way you're right you
know like i think we're about to get a
lot of really pretty stuff
really easily yeah and people will be
able to make it real they can right now
you know if they can just download an
app they can do it right
15 bucks a month or whatever it is yeah
you know but like that's the the thing
though it's like still so it's pictures
you know i'm like now like you know will
it be 3d next
or will it be like 3d like actual like
is there anything having temporal
consistency
yeah it's like the moment you can make a
video clip that's cool like but you know
yeah it's it's like it's it's a thing
where at the same time you know a cool
piece of concept art it's like once
again brilliant artists
you know put time into that
but you know that's not like that's not
the draw the concept art is all it's
like a thing a tool to make something
bigger you know what i'm saying like so
it's like all right are you making like
actual video content or music or like
writing a book or it's like something
that
you know has the weight or gravity of an
experience and like thought behind it
and
you know it feels like there's still a
bit of time before that happens although
although yeah so that's the thing i i i
still i'm gonna make this ai book i
think you're gonna make an ai book yeah
what is it
like a book entirely written with nlp
uh it's gpt three yeah yeah yeah and
then uh basically
well i'm not gonna talk about it too
much right now okay but uh
it's gonna happen very quickly
i'm just saying that's that's the thing
about ai it's quick yeah super fast you
can make iterations after iterations
yeah and like you know
i think what's worth talking about here
like a lot of our discussions are like
in the future it will be in the future
your fridge will tell when you're hungry
and it'll play music for you like you
know and there's a lot of this in the
future talk but like what's really
exciting is right now that in the future
talk is stopping and now it's right now
yeah um
when we went up to film our we did a
collab with adam savage back the
beginning of summer
mid journey came out and on the car
right on yeah we were all playing yeah
it was cool
i saw the instagram post oh my god
it was amazing going up there and
filming that video with them yeah but
mid journey just came out and we're like
this is really neat and of course it's
wacky it's very interpretive and whatnot
yeah and then dolly too comes out and i
was like holy moly
and stable diffusion comes out and we're
like wow right this is even better than
dolly two and dolly two just came out
right like why is this going so fast and
then mid journey put it the majority
comes out with a new model yeah and then
the disabled division comes out with 1.6
or 1.5 and then like and now we're like
all this new software is coming out
around it because it's all open source
and it is moving
so fast yeah like they're going to be
releasing the new model for people to
download in like two weeks or so
supposedly and it's just like whoa
whoa like guys i i blinked i blinked and
dolly too came and went yeah like i was
expecting this
like imagine steve jobs invents the
iphone
and then two weeks later like the
implant for your brain comes out it's
like whoa just like i would like to use
the iphone like a year
yeah right like i'm trying to think of
like what gpt5 is going to be right
forget about ggp4 it's going to blow our
blow our brains away right is that a
thing americans say
okay sure
like
dpt4 is going to be like oh my gosh this
sounds like humans yeah i try to like
get a little help every once in a while
writing a screenplay um but with gpc3 uh
but you can only use so many tokens
right you can only
tell it so much right to to remember so
much uh so like i had to i had it right
like just the end of my i was trying to
get like one perfect final thing right
just the end of it right and i first
messed up where i didn't just give it
like one line so it gave me like a whole
new alternate ending
uh where it was like
he looks her in the eyes and she looks
him in the eyes and it's like i wish we
had met earlier you know and it's like i
have those years ago in tokyo right 25
years ago like stop stop and like as
they get closer to kiss i'm like stop
stop stop stop there
it's the dad and she's nine
but then i fed more of it into it and i
was the website went down or something
and i was like okay whatever i'm just
going to the shower and like think about
the lion like do the old-fashioned way i
guess
to the point where my wife was like it's
a drought get out of there i'm like i'm
thinking about a line uh so i did
and i i came up with this like eureka
moment i'm like this is what she's gonna
say to him at the very end
and like i had tears i had like
goosebumps i went to the computer and
went to go write it and the website
hadn't gone down the website was just
like thinking and it came up with
something that was really close
really close i was really mad
that's really scary
and i'm like yeah
that's it's not it's not it's not as
good as mine
but it's really close i would have
gotten to mine faster hadn't seen
yes you know and like gpt4 is gonna make
some stuff that's like i wouldn't have
thought of that yeah what's gpt5 what's
gpt 10
you know what's that going to do it's
going to invent
stuff that humans as a collective have
not been able to
invent in a really long time yeah and
what if when you what would you start
applying it to other things that aren't
writing in pictures you know
just we're all obviously very close to
that because it's what we all do for a
living yeah
yeah it's it's really bonkers and it's
like and these what-ifs aren't really
what-ifs anymore the fact that you did
that with gpt-3 already it's like and
gpt-3 is kind of old news now it is yeah
it's like we're beyond that like yeah
everybody's just finding out about this
kind of stuff like no guy like
it's
so happy it's changing so fast and like
yeah there's also all these questions
about like steganography and like you
know hiding stuff in the images to be
like this is ai yeah you can get around
that or gpt3 being used for like uh
this like actual discord not the the app
but like creating discord on twitter you
know like racist comments and like being
used for that you know and like
what do we do we write an ai that can
tell that when something is ai or not
but then that gender series networks
that's it right like you're just you're
just creating ai's that can fight with
each other
and that exists yeah that exists as gans
yeah yeah yeah that's what it is
but then like
then it's gonna be like all right um
only
stop when you get better than a human
you know uh only right yeah a better
sonnet uh you know or only uh stop until
you figure out exactly every single time
whether or not this microscope slide has
cancer you know yeah um or like uh
like would flint have happened if you
know ai were around you know on the
pipes i don't know um ai is just too
catch-all of a term right it's too much
it's just like computers doing work yeah
it's it's the magic of ai as i explained
in a few other podcasts it's being able
to write a computer program without
having to actually write the program
yeah going here's the result i'm wanting
here's the inputs i have
here's some examples that you can
practice on and what the you know quote
unquote correct answers are yeah you
come up with other programming you need
to do to give you the correct answers
i'm not going to do that i'll just give
you the answers
and it's like the fact that our
computers are so fast like okay well
just monkeys banging on the typewriter
let's go
and it's like okay we banged the
typewriter you know a couple trillion
times and we actually came up with a
math equation that worked you only feed
the monkeys that bang the right things
right exactly right and then all the
monkeys learn how to bring the right
things into the typewriters right you
also you have you put them in the room
where you put on the
the nice music the monkeys are treated
really well just so you know as they're
learning well the monkeys that are doing
well they're trying to get more money
the monkeys who can't type sonnets they
leave
[Laughter]
yeah so why have you not slept for the
past two and a half weeks is it just
because you can do concept art or is
there something deeper
i i it's partly i mean it's so
multifactorial right uh and i have slept
a little bit uh you know i just have
messed up my my sleep schedule a lot um
it's because it's so quick you know
literally i i was like working on uh
some code for something and then someone
was like hey yeah here's the code uh i
had my thing do it you know and it's
like oh here's the better one here's a
better one here's a better so i i cut
and this is getting to people like
people are texting me
uh or chatting me dming me like hey i'm
gonna like
check myself in somewhere like and
um get some help um and i'm like oh wow
like it it's like
an addiction for some people right and i
have to stop myself from it becoming an
addiction um for sure you know um and
but but really
some of the factors include
i feel like my job and everybody's job
is on the line i feel like i could make
some money because i'm gonna be first uh
i feel like
uh i can finally express some of the
stuff that i've been wanting to i can't
draw like you two can you know uh you
could you can draw way better than i can
you know like i i
my dad when i was uh 12 years old uh put
me into art class uh because i like
entered an art context because the ev
every single person who entered won a
goldfish i just wanted the goldfish and
i drew the worst jim carrey in the mask
that you can possibly imagine
i don't really want it
now it was just oh yeah i know that's it
this is the this is that's the story
that's why he's up he's looking for this
redemption this is it i can image the
image of that in that thing to create
the perfect mask jim carrey in the mask
you know like and i remember looking at
all the other drawings and being like
how how do you do that like what how do
you move your foot but the thing is even
if you do image to image it and it looks
great like that's not
that doesn't solve the problem but then
is it mine i drew the original thing
is it just the photoshop filter it's
pretend it's pretend pretend of mine
it's pretending that you drew it better
yeah it is
how about pretending though is that not
what the eq is when you're mixing music
is that not what they sharpen
you pretending like you is that how the
lookup tables are you apply to your
footage when you color grade it well i
guess it's just that's the thing where
it's like we just need to find like is
there a level here or is this like this
new concept of thinking where
it's not about
like the concept quality is not a
concept or craft is no longer a concept
you know what i'm saying where it's like
okay well dude when you build a house
craft is a concept all right yeah does
it stay up when it rains does it fall
apart you know like there's some you
know i'm gonna when it comes to like art
it's kind of like it's getting to this
point where no there's no it like it's
i just that that's the part that's still
spooky where it's like ah man and for
art especially right because art is so
personal and art means so much to so
many people we're like
well but it's that concept of getting it
like i you know like what what happens
when the collective collective
consciousness moves to a point
where
craft is like taken for granted and is
we're
not
like
a thing we're already there remember
this this topic's about how things move
so fast we're already we're at the point
where people take craft for a while
shoot i do i know like the last decade
we make youtube videos
we know what like we've seen that
already we're going to be the old people
in in like two weeks being like why i
remember back in the day where this this
things just didn't model themselves the
fact that people were like uh you know
what the new marvel do you edit your
videos oh my god what
happens they have auto editors now you
can like cut things out from the script
i know we're here right you use it you
use it right
like
so like that's gonna be everything
sorry are movies gonna be kevin feige
with a laptop in his basement and that's
it yeah i mean right the fact that
people are not already
who sells you
a apple watch all right defense kevin
like i really am i'm a huge fan of your
work it's no it's it's general
it's elon musk sells you the neural link
and then you put that in your head yeah
and then basically it takes that
biometric data and then is basically on
the fly trying to come up with prompts
that stimulate you and you're just
sitting there going like here we go
like that's it that's it that's the
[ __ ] dystopia it's so gross you're
right that is incredibly dystopian we're
already there man it's just we have
phone screens so it's not quite as like
you know it doesn't hit you quite as
well yeah it's like here yeah that's
literally what tick-tock is
tick-tock is is that's why it's gross
people going like all right we need a
way to like you know it's the closest
thing to ai generated videos like let's
just give people the tools millions of
people well yeah obviously you do have
ai generated videos uh rocket jumps uh
like uh like funny thing about it like
they're they're all of these videos that
are trying to like grab your attention
right and they literally put something
up on the screen and then underneath it
is like look it's minecraft like
realistic minecraft stuff uh and it's
really like a play for your uh attention
and
you know
it's
they now have started making those
automatically where it just takes like
top reddit comments and a voice a text
to the voice or text-to-speech thing is
like what is the favor what's your
favorite thing this is what this part
and like it's there's thousands of those
they get millions of views
a generational thing i was talking about
this with my wife and she's like
kids are [ __ ] but crap yes
craft right like
if if i watch a movie with an actor in
it
am i like if it makes me cry and i'm
like who is that actor and i go and i
look it up and it's little michaela or
whatever like some ai
thing right
am i gonna feel bad about it did you
feel bad about rogue one and like
tarkin being fake you know did you
notice did most people notice that i
don't know i don't know
right man i don't know games are going
to become this movies are going to
become this that line is going to be
blurred you're going to be able to you
know you're kind of bored with a movie
grab the controllers actually don't even
grab the controls just just go over
there a little bit more like open the
door right like yeah it's gonna be like
those choose your own adventure
but
like
more yeah and perhaps not
by your choosing
you know if you're wearing like a uh a
watch and even if you're not the tv has
a little uh webcam on top of it and it's
going to look at your face and it's
going to look when you're okay i can't
do this anymore guys
i can't do this and then it's going to
know exactly what stimulates you in just
the right way let's talk about the
waifus again
it's scary isn't it it's scary sam i
have some quality waifus to show you i'm
kidding i mean i do but
they're easy it's like stable diffusion
is really easy to generate waifu's on i
bet yeah are we going to get into a
whole fanboy conversation now where he
just walks away or what yeah this is if
we're gonna dim the lights and it fades
out and i i leave and you guys and i'm
like keep talking and it just
quietly it goes to zero so what do you
what do you think about like imogen
versus party and like is that
you know do i get it
i do actually have the bounce a 100 so
this is a
it always ends on a low note i'm sorry
it's not a low note
it does i'm like oh god you're going to
live longer because of it and happier i
think joe
if sam heads out i'd love to still talk
for 15 minutes after this all right you
guys can do your deep dive so
the layman myself
uh gets to leave
the luddite yes yes i know the luddite
angle is leaving guys so watch out all
right see you later
lamer uh
[Laughter]
do you want to see what a
harley-davidson iphone would look like
let's let's make it right
all right for all you guys
and gals still listening
and non-binary people and non-binary and
robots
like non-human people
do you think we're gonna get into a like
a thing where it's like do you remember
how rude we were to robots back in the
day yeah do you think that that's gonna
be a thing when they were you know we're
talking about like
yeah you know robots writes i was
talking to so you heard about the guy
that one engineer at google who's like
you're oh that guy's yeah that goofball
yeah all right just want to say i looked
at the logs i think he's full of it he's
full of it he starts out with being like
hey by the way you're the smartest thing
that ever existed and you definitely uh
like are sentient so are you saying you
know so how are you yes it's playing a
game you know it's playing a game with
him you know the one thing is like at no
point at no point in the log the machine
ever asked him
about something machine is interested in
at no point did it take on its own
volition and initiative to learn about
something that's true it always just
just responses which is exactly what it
does it's a it's a statistics machine
you type these words statistically this
response will fit at best that's all it
is there's a you know you know about the
saturn v supercomputer that not the
saturn v rocket but the satirification
that nvidia has you know like
20 000 gpus that are running whatever
right so one of the people that the
french guy uh i forgot his name uh but
like he's working on in videos like
self-driving car autonomous vehicle
stuff right
um he was talking about how that's the
next big thing right now
everything that we have is just pattern
recognition
right it's just like really good pattern
recognition and and but it's really
really good right
but that's all it has kind of like um
and you can create new patterns you can
join different patterns together but it
doesn't have its own volition its own
thoughts its own
like wills yeah
do we want it to because the i've seen a
movie with arnold that i wasn't a huge
fan of and that definitely had wills i'm
not sure if it can quite ever have the
same way we do because it's not the same
system right you know it's like that guy
in that computer it's like it's talking
about feelings like
feelings are not something that can
exist via the human definition and
something that is not human because
feelings require more than just your
neurons is that you saying this or is
that what that's that's what i'm saying
yeah it's like feelings require
an organic body they require endorphins
they acquire chemicals they require
senses they require all these things
for happiness to truly be a human
emotion you have to be a human to
experience it a computer cannot
experience happiness and experience the
computer equivalent of happiness right
and like in that guy that said like oh
this machine's sentient it's like it's
talking about stuff it's like dude you
can't you're anthropomorphizing it like
you need to understand biology behind
these things like we're not computers
like
but i don't know what if i what if i can
never know let's digress i like this
digression uh what if i can model
your neurons perfectly ship of theseus
right like if i can take just this
little part of your brain
that isn't working or whatever right and
i can fix you up and now it's a chip
right
and then slowly i i change it over and
more and more and more and more and in
fact you know what the rest of the butt
from here down it doesn't matter anyway
right it's just like sensors simulate it
right yeah yeah it's just like
mechanical levers or whatever right we
we we get like new knees and we don't
say now you're an android you know
you're like
a little bit yeah yeah
if the person has the green texts then
we do say oh now you have an android
that's a really bad joke can you please
cut that out
but you know like
well i think if you emulate a human
being perfectly let's just say right
unless you believe in something like a
soul
then it's going to think that it's a
human being and it's going to have
uh an idea of what happiness is if you
emulate it perfectly but
i was talking another body of mine who's
also big into ai logan olsen a bunch of
people probably know him uh from back in
the day and i should bring him in for a
podcast too
and we're talking about this and i was
like so do you think the computer is
sent or not what's your take he's like
i think the idea of calling it sentient
is an outdated term that's going to be
irrelevant by the time we actually have
this discussion yes it's like what is
sentience who cares it's an outdate yeah
who cares it doesn't matter it's not how
good is it right like what what is what
what is the loss while you're you're
doing the training you know like what
like what like who cares right like yeah
does that arbitrarily define sentience
after like 1960s sci-fi novel definition
like who cares right like it's it's so
you're right it's anthropocentric right
like
it's
okay so i have a question for you what
is
what's the opposite of a puppy ooh
now the comment is not for you for you
for me that well
the common answer would be kitty i hate
to say it i know the trick question you
do you do know the true question
um the opposite of a puppy is actually a
beige dresser sitting on a beach
actually i don't know
right uh yeah so i would say a cat
personally right a puppy is a cat for us
humans yeah the opposite of a puppy is a
cat right um or a kitten actually right
but but no it's oh my god no a cat would
be farther away because it's older at
least you know like the the visual
opposite for a computer of a puppy
is like a puppy and a kitten are almost
identical yeah they're both animals pets
legs so yeah they're close together
you're right four legs they both are
indoors all the time they're cute you
know uh
so like
let's see what the i can literally ask
the computer right now like what is the
opposite of a puppy like the true
opposite the true visual opposite of a
puppy
uh and in just about
three seconds
it's going to show us
this is a room where anybody can
generate so i hope that
uh
nobody generates some some weird stuff
in here
okay it is a house in the suburbs
or like a dollar bill
23 bill right like but this this is the
opposite this is the visual opposite of
a puppy right like you see that over
there
yeah it's like an aerial view of a house
it's an area view of a floridian in a
floridian cul-de-sac
uh
it's an executive home uh in in spring
nice rambler beautiful uh like
uh some beautiful uh topiary work right
the yard is freshly mowed yes uh that is
the opposite of
they don't have cars they have
uh
they have like blow up mattresses on
there
and they're
like
shiny car blobs that is the opposite of
uh a puppy and if i were to describe
this image perfectly um as in like if i
would say like hey give me an aerial
drone view of this
floridian executive home it probably
give me pets yeah yeah the inverse of
that yeah yeah right um so
we don't think like computers and
computers don't think like us and yet ai
its specific task is
think exactly like humans please you
know
draw like humans please
or
tell us when humans are sick or drive
like humans but then it's like oh but
don't do the mistakes don't do the the
bad stuff that humans do right yes
is that what human beings are like if i
had to invent about like
a saying i'd say like to air is human
i i didn't invent that but you know like
like did you just come up with that one
you know
[Laughter]
what is what is a human being right like
in this context i don't know right i
mean the reality of it to a certain
extent it's like we're
we're organic machines you know
neural networks in computer learning
they're called neural networks because
they're they work the same way our
neurons do which is basically a bunch of
interference patterns a bunch of weights
on impulses
because just like with machine learning
life
you're given the results and the answers
but you didn't come up with the
programming it was
all right survive
you know if you survive you pass you die
you fail yeah and we're gonna kill all
the things that don't survive we're
gonna keep things that do survive yeah
and that was your machine learning like
iteration right so much of our brains
are based on
like fear right the people who survived
were not the ones who were looking up at
the stars and being like oh wow that one
kind of looks like a guy uh with an
archer
shoot okay that's a lion all right i'm
dead
you know like
uh or like why are those moving
wandering ones and those aren't you know
uh it wasn't until much later uh
that we figured it out you know it's
like we went from being hunters to being
hunter-gatherers
to creating images of homer simpson
uh in the godfather you know i think
there's some other stuff in between but
like
i do i do have a wacky wacky out there
philosophy that's me
in the uh i forgot that i signed the uh
okay no go for it
sorry you're my wacky out there
philosophy yeah no you got your little
signature on the wall yeah yeah you can
you can say it again yeah yeah
i went adhd on you so
you know often we go on like one little
rides and we go like to the top of the
mountains around l.a yeah sitting on the
top of the mountain looking at the city
it's like this kind of looks like
this the cells in a leaf or like you
know a lichen you know what's growing on
the the ground you're looking it's like
there's the arteries you know the the
highways are like the arteries and they
split into smaller veins and branches
and you have
you have your nervous system with like
you know communications in the internet
oh i know where you're going with this
you know it's like
so when you when you look at a
biological system you have cells and you
have like cellular structures and you
have like organ like you have organs and
you have organ systems and like ins like
nico perringer is a single living
creature
that's not actually true nico pairing is
actually like billions of tiny living
creatures yes it's called cells all
working together yeah and they form an
entity called nico you know yeah yeah
and when you kind of step out and you
look at society from a bird's eye view
literally on top of a mountain you start
to be like man all these people are now
just more advanced cells building an
advanced system
and that system we're building isn't
done yet we're still building it and
it's like is that system we're building
just a higher
being
are we just built like okay we've built
the systems to feed ourselves now we
need to be build systems to move
ourselves around the body we need to
build systems for us to communicate we
need to build a system for this you know
new organism to be able to like breathe
and eat etc and you know process energy
it needs to be able to you know
communicate with its various parts
and are we now finally building the
brain
of the system are we as the little cells
you know building our big organism and
like the brain is finally getting
constructed i wish i smoked weed
right now man i wish i i wish i was high
uh that's that's and this is what like
all of the galaxies that we have all
around us looks like you know like
are we going to then
become like what like a type whatever
civilization right like that that uses
it's the energy of its sun you know or
or many suns out there and like but
you're right like oh on earth are we
we're just the red blood cells of a
bigger creature so to speak and yeah
yeah obviously i like technically
speaking of creature like i get it i get
it it's a concept right but still that's
a gossip yeah yeah but it's a great
concept because like
you know
i think
a lot of us we are so anthropocentric
right we are very much like the earth is
here for the taking and i will take
whatever i should and if we're the brain
then it is our duty to
to keep this earth
safe to keep our you know to like we
want to be saved you know like the brain
like
there's so much that your body does to
save your brain right in your heart like
whenever you're you're like when you're
cold your fingers start to hurt because
we can lose those and survive you know
keep this keep this going you know you
don't want to pass out um so
you know like
when that's the case and we see
ourselves as the brain of this earth
then yeah i do see how we we start
getting to responsibility of humankind
you know and and how
you know i'm at least the kind of person
who thinks we're going to become star
trek and not uh mad max fury road yeah i
think it's as good as that movie
assuming that resources on the planet
don't run now but doesn't i don't think
that's the case i think we're we'll
figure it out we'll have ai figure it
out for us while we're making images uh
we're watching our our movies yeah you
know or like writing or harley
davidson's i guess
uh iphone harley davidson all right
yeah
do you think they're kind of figuring it
out like we're in the process yeah yeah
do you think that there
is going to be a a period in between
of of hurt
where
a lot of people who hire people are
going to be hiring machines instead
actually i mean
jobs always go out of date right
technology moves forward and that puts
jobs out of date it doesn't mean that
as you have taking a net loss on jobs
necessarily i'm sure some people are
going to come in they're like well
but generally speaking
technology moves forward and it empowers
people to have more output
and when you have more output it
actually creates more demand for things
when it's like oh
clothes can be cheap
suddenly more people want clothes right
now more people can afford clothes right
oh art's cheap more people want art
it's easy to make art more people are
going to make art it's it doesn't work
the opposite it's like oh art's cheap
and now you can just to snap my fingers
well i'm not going to take any more art
than except for
one movie a year it's like no if you
could watch the perfect movie every
night starring you and your friends yes
like it'd be like video games right
right you get into it and suddenly like
give me more give me oh my god i didn't
even think of that like you're
absolutely right like staring you and
your friends right like yeah we live
vicariously through
whatever you know like
if there's a a generative movie or or
whatever that move that term is going to
be so outdated
like there's a generative piece of
oh god content i'm not going to say
content i hate that
you're watching something on something
right like it's either in your eyes or
in the screen if we want to be like oh
let's be old school and watch it on the
screen uh and you know
you get to sit down with your friends
and like the jokes that you made
that you make are the jokes that that
guy makes you know and like there's like
a funny like in-joke that
you know we do that anyway we live
vicariously through actors and actresses
and
and and things like oh i want to be that
person i want to be iron man i want to
be this
when you can see yourself in it you know
that's pretty freaking cool yeah right
we're definitely like moving towards a
like
subjective narrative
society yeah it's like you are going to
be the narrative that you want i mean
you kind we all kind of are right you go
to college you invent yourself right
yeah be a different person in college
and you were in high school yeah that's
just that's the same thing except now
it's like i online i'm going to look
like this i'm going to sound like this
i'm going to act like this
you know i can be whatever i want
whoever i want i can have whatever
backstory i want who are you to tell me
how i should feel you know it's like why
aren't my emotions valid i am now this
and that's the society we're kind of
already in you know like people are very
pushing to like accept that yeah
but that's kind of the human condition
you know sure so it's it's very you got
into philosophy really fast yeah what
about when humans are
uh if you gotta go you gotta go you let
me know no no i'm good i'm good i did
the pockets or something
it's worth mentioning that we have had a
discord yeah we set up like four days
ago
so we could talk about all this ai stuff
and now we get to finally talk in person
right so like we're very excited about
this as some people out there oh sorry
what about when human beings are a
liability in the system you're talking
about how
it's like increasing output right
when it's like no no no don't don't
drive
you know uh actually you're gonna ban
driving or
surgery by a human being what is this
the the 2010s the 2020s
don't do that yeah right um
yeah they're gonna get removed out of it
yeah
but when it comes down to it's like you
go back to the artist thing right like
okay let's get out of the like oh you
know who what's going to happen in the
future like right now right you are
let's you're a concept artist you're
working in the film industry oh boy what
else do you do
yeah yeah it's like so right now
no there's literally a tool that just
came out that can replace you kind of
right yeah yeah because it's not
replacing you it's not a tool it's like
if you our concept artists need refuse
to learn photoshop yeah you're gonna
fall off the train yes you're a concept
artist now and you don't use any of
these ai tools you're going to fall off
the train they aren't replacing you it's
just a new tool set and you have to
learn how to use it it's it's a way for
you to
i mean you can train it on your own
style you can do it eventually like when
this comes out it's all going to be like
we know this what do you mean yeah
everyone's gonna be like oh we've been
on this app for 24 hours what do you
mean
like you know yeah it's like being you
know cinematographers like i shoot film
it's like well you better learn how to
use the alexa no that's that's done man
what's gonna happen is we're gonna have
like some sort of capture right and i've
been talking to vfx people about this
yeah capturing system right it's not
going to be light alright that's too
slow but like some sort of like camera
these cameras right all around and then
sets are going to become like place
right like where i'm like okay let's
just go ahead and we're not going to set
up a thing over here and it's like hey
actually when you read the when you look
at the
the picture can you actually look at it
like this
go ahead i'm about to ruin movies for
you you know whenever you see a movie
like the amount of people who hold stuff
like this yeah i was like oh this image
that i care very much about but like
why why because
this way it makes sense
for you to be able to see it so like
that kind of stuff like it won't be
necessary anymore because i'll just be
able to move their hands in in post
right or move the camera or like do
something you showed me the test you're
doing
uh
with sylvester stallone yeah we trained
so
no i didn't do it it was someone else
but what's this okay so we're talking
about stable diffusion here but whatever
i'm gonna all these ai image generation
systems i'm just gonna say they're the
same they're not i'm just gonna say they
are i'm gonna piss off everybody who
actually works on them right they're all
kind of the same
so somebody's like well you can type in
sylvester stallone it gives you a weird
kind of goofy picture of sylvester
stallone but he kind of looks like him
like you know it's like it's the
character character of him right it's
the defining features they're kind of
wobbly and weird and gooby yeah and so
because it's got rocky he's got rocks
and it's got like
now sylvester is like older so it's like
it doesn't know how old he is and
doesn't know and when you ask for like
30 year old sylvester stallone it
doesn't give you yet it will in like two
days
it doesn't give you like 30 year old
like he looks like rocky it gives you
like
what 30 year old men look like plus
sylvester stallone so yeah it's wonky
right yeah 100
but then somebody's like well
let me just train it a little bit more
and so on specifically on sylvester
stallone like clearly sylvester stallone
exists in the cultural site guys he
exists in the mall you can type his name
it's like let me just make a couple
extra pictures and just explicitly do a
little more training on sylvester
stallone like
10 pictures maybe of him just here's 10
more right
and then when it goes okay give me a
picture sylvester stallone now once that
little extra bit of training is done
it's like whoa that looks exactly like
him and here's a different angle and
here's a different angle yeah and the
thing is like it's just taking like okay
i have like 10 pictures of sylvester
stallone but in my mind i literally have
a billion pictures of everything so i
can feel in the gaps yeah i can't see
the back of his head i can guess he has
black hair let me guess the hair on the
back of his head is also black it's like
it can the the system's doing that and
it's
it's got your hair man yeah in the
little test that we did it's the same
thing like yeah other people have hair
like the system can fill in what my hair
looks like
you know as long as it as long as it
sees a picture it's like okay i can i
can bs my way through every other
picture now right which is basically how
it works and so it's like it really is
besting its way like
it's like a college student that like
figured out just enough amount of work
that it's got to do you know like
exactly i mean that's the human way it's
the it's like
it is sentient it's a human [ __ ] it's a
person
but uh
you know
that the thing is like so okay now it
comes to like movies or picture books or
whatever it's like
well
i don't need to record a scene with
sylvester stallone i'll record a scene
with my buddy
and i'll like i'll roughly get it kind
of right i'll say well you know here's a
guy
make that sylvester stallone it's like
and clearly you can do it you can put
out perfect pictures of him now it's
really one of the picture in here yeah
rogue one that's what it was right uh
and that took like a lot of artists a
lot of work a lot of time yeah um it's
not gonna anymore no no or like uh uh
gosh uh uh the the irishman right yeah
irishman the the pull on three cameras
version of like one of these image
generators yeah but instead of training
a defect what are you just trying to
d-pick on all the pictures of everything
in the entire world right and you said
give me a picture of this box or of
sylvester stallone or of a cat it's like
well i'll just deep fake that because i
roughly know what casts look like okay
but specifically here's ten pictures of
my cat so okay all i can fill in the
details but now i can draw your cat
perfectly from every angle yeah and if i
can draw your cat perfectly from every
angle well you can literally just make a
movie and you never have to touch a
camera or you can touch your camera and
i'll just use that as a guide for where
i'll put everything yeah i know that you
said it like this you know and i'll be
able to like
stretch out it's animation right like uh
animation does that so well but
animation is going to become
photorealistic right
um
and granted
we still ride horses today you know like
we still listen to music we still go to
orchestras i have a painting of uh
like a pretty kind of sort of like photo
realistic um
uh jar of colored pencils right and i i
love that painting and and it's like
it's hung up in my house i can make that
painting real fast right now but it's
hung up in my house because i can
picture the person like
being like i'm just going to do that i'm
just going to do that right there
right and and so or took a picture of it
and then worked from the picture
probably uh but that's okay because like
i can see the the brush strokes and i
know that there's a human in there right
and i love that
and i i hear what sam like i'm i'm i
think i'm it's the seat you need to move
them
and it's it's this becomes a detector if
if i had that emotion of like imagining
that person toiling over this painting
and then like you know like selling it
and like making a living doing that like
what an amazing thing that this person
has done if you had told me then it's
like oh actually it was a machine that
went like
you know like like an automation machine
that did it
it would feel lesser than you know or
like for example some
you know there's some historical
pictures that may be released of
something that happened that was
horrific that happened like years and
years ago and people are like they don't
trust this guy who's like a pawn shop
guy who's like i found pictures of this
thing right this like horrible
historical event um
if those pictures are released and
you know it makes a splash but then it
comes out that like
in a year that's like oh actually we
have like an ai checker thing and it
those pictures were fake
that would even though that might
actually have happened and have been
close
yeah i don't know you know they're all
these questions like i can very easily
catfish somebody right now you know i
can just use an image to image with like
not that high strength and say okay
that's not joe penna that's jamie dornan
you know
actually now he's a little stronger so
like oh i can have a real good-looking
tinder
i don't thankfully i'm married i'm
happily married i don't want to get into
tinder because now i i don't know who
i'm going to trust not in there anymore
you know like it's just i don't know man
i don't know like there are problems
with it with biases and like ethics and
like how do you fix it do you you have
to make an effort to fix it i think yeah
but what is that effort right that's a
very good question because like the
other thing too is like you see these
incredibly powerful technologies coming
out i was like this is going to change
the world it's like okay well do it
yeah it's like oh you actually want me
to do that right now like yeah change
like as in like this is powerful so
where's the software so it's right here
it's like you that python code no no
where's the software like you know yes
yes where's my tools right yeah and the
big thing i've been seeing like
so with stable diffusion you know they
released everything all the code the
model
and it's been incredible the amount of
tools that have been coming out where
people are just making stuff and going
like oh let's do it like this this might
be useful yeah then a thousand people
ten thousand people use like that
they're like okay actually we like this
feature it's like oh okay well i'll add
that feature yeah and like suddenly
we've seen what would probably take
companies months if not like a year to
put out it's like happening literally in
two weeks two weeks yeah yeah it's it's
it's bonkers but then
you step back and you're like wait a
minute
if this is how open source is happening
around machine learning and so much of
machine learning is open source yeah
someone which is that is built on open
source yeah it's kind of like what's
going to happen to all these like
software companies and corporations like
what's going to happen to adobe
because
or heck even
like 3d programs like
unreal engine like you know obviously
there's more to unreal engine than just
the renderer but it's like you know so
many people worked so hard yeah to make
unreal engine 5 be able to render what
it can render and like a crazy lighting
system it's like
or i just have an ai that knows how to
paint photorealistic things like just
like a human being you can train a human
being to draw a photo and paint
photorealistic things like so here's the
rough geometry make it look real and
goes okay and it just makes it look real
it makes it consistent it's like and i
don't need to do any rendering i don't
need to do any math i don't need to like
have
photons be calculated and shadows be
calculated in like you know various
surface materials because so you need to
calculate its precise location on the
latent space
yeah
give me the xy coordinates of the latent
space uh oh you're using a two
dimensional latent space man that's so
24 hours ago
it's multi-dimensional there's 64
vectors that you got to use at least
you know
um yeah no um you're right like it's
uh
it's i think it's very dependent on what
you think of twitter in a way right like
if you think that twitter was
a boon
for humanity
versus and make up your mind
viewers at home you know or listeners at
home please listen i don't know which
one you make more money that's okay uh
okay
i just wanted to be here with us if
you're here with us just just close your
eyes and and make a judgment call right
now you have aphasia do you unless all
right just
or at least just you know if if you
can't picture it just just imagine
the words of like is twitter
good or bad for society you know
and whether or not whether
i can i can i i can destroy whatever
answer you pick because if you say it's
bad i say well what about arab spring
what about like the fact that that it
used to be the the you know
all these things right like that twitter
is great you know like it's giving
people who don't have privileged voices
or privileged like stances like obsessed
with people connect easier connect
easier people how about all people who
fell in love through twitter people who
like uh who are talking to uh
researchers for ai who used to be
youtubers and now are filmmakers who now
get to say like excuse me uh thank you
for saying that you've been watching all
my videos for a long time
i i really need help with this python
though uh
what about all of that right yeah but
then she said no no it's good it's great
okay what about all the bad stuff what
about the fact that like or facebook or
things like that you know like they
literally there's that one test that
they made that they only showed people
angry things did you see that or like
sad things and it made people post sad
things which is completely against the
ethics of psychological studies right
like you're literally trying to
but did they know that that's what was
going to happen i mean they should have
guessed yes you don't do you don't do a
negative
well i mean misusing the term negative
for a test here but you don't need to do
negative results without letting your
participants be informed right it's like
a hundred percent against the ethics of
yeah but was it was it buried in the tos
somewhere you know the terms of service
that facebook may
purposely make you unhappy uh you know
like uh or instagram like people talk
about all that stuff you know so like
whenever you take all that into account
you know you can see that twitter
facebook web 2.0
is a tool that can be used for good and
bad right
it can get trump elected it can it can
uh
it can get people's tweets out of
ukraine you know uh it can it can do
both
right but oh did i say
i get i'm getting political sorry i got
political there i didn't realize i got
political i i thought it was kind of uh
it's okay just oh well uh i don't think
it's a hot take to say that trump's
analysis oh isn't that okay good yeah
so the stable effusion ai
generative images are going to be the
same thing right uh and who owns openai
it's reid hoffman and elon musk to
multi-billionaires right um is that bad
is that good
i think i think it's good because then
they can put some money into something
that can
whatever right the way that i saw it
said about stable effusion was
and about the ai in general is
it's bad really bad for a small number
of people you're a concept artist
like learn how to use this for now you
know like so you can you can extend how
long you're going to be working but what
else what else you got what else you can
do
you're uh
you know with music what's coming that
up this dance diffusion or whatever you
know i'm seeing some stuff that like i'm
gonna load all my stuff into it and
maybe i'll make youtube videos again
because it's gonna be so easy you know
like
eventually it's going to be a better
artist than all of us right
so
there are the people of us the subset of
people of us that are artists
that are better than the other ones
that's bad for them but it's better for
it's great for everyone else right if
you believe that that everyone being
able to be an artist is great right some
some detractors down some luddites
down
i know he's right he's got a lot of good
points right
so who knows um
i think that it's exciting to be at the
forefront and i do think that we should
check each other on how much we sleep
yes uh we need to sleep get it full
eight hours well not until not until we
finish the training
after we do the training and and check
to make sure that the training is
running yeah first just make sure and
then then we can go to sleep but you
have to do have to set an alarm every 10
minutes and make sure the training is
going well right or just train an ai
well it takes 15 minutes you just give
me some of your pictures and you got it
oh man this is fascinating yeah let's go
figure out how to ai can tell uh when we
got cancer and then we're good yeah then
i thought they had dogs that could like
smell cancer dogs are old hat you're
right those are bad machines now they
have florida executive houses floridian
drone views of floridian executive homes
we need the opposite of dogs that can
smell cancer which is floridian executor
home but instead of blow up mattresses
on the driveway they have
i don't know lsgpt3
you let us know in the comments down
below like if you're listening to
someone that has come
what what a i told you the end of that
joke was going to be anyway
all right last thing here i think to
wrap this up so chances are people are
listening to this and a bunch of people
probably know about mid journey and
people have used it well let's go into
just like a moment here of like hey you
listening right now you want to get in
on this ai train here's what you do all
right first don't don't do it it's not
worth it
it's all right just just we'll figure it
out for you and just please get out get
out of our space yeah like this is the
only shot and we're keeping it that way
no specifically um if you want to dabble
and you want things to look pretty right
off the bat check out the mid journey
discord uh just literally sign up to the
discord channel read the
introduction thing follow the
instructions and you'll start making
images but you're probably going to
realize that a it's kind of slow you can
only get one or two images every minute
or so
and two eventually you have to start
paying for it um but you know what
probably worth it especially when you're
experimenting but the slowness can be a
thing majority is just going to give you
really pretty pictures all the time well
that's because of the full clip guidance
you know like at least you're not going
to get some some like doubles or
anything like that but the fact that
it's full
full clip guidance with all the vectors
let's not get into stochastic training
go ahead so let's say you want to go a
little bit deeper this is where you
should probably check out stable
diffusion yeah if you have like
a decent gpu um like we're talking like
2080 or above
arguably even like slower gpus can
handle it finally if you get the
optimized versions but if you have a
decent gpu and you want to sit down and
learn a little bit of python code and
learning how to use like anaconda
it's worth checking out there's a bunch
of different repos you can go to the
stable diffusion subreddit r stable
diffusion the top faq how do i run this
there's a bunch of links there there's a
bunch of different options to get you
started you can get it running on your
own computer
meaning you it's free you can generate
as many images as you want you can make
literally whatever you want uh so please
be responsible
um
but you can get running on your own
system and you can make it happen and if
you want to use table diffusion without
running it on your computer they have
their own like web based stream studio
yeah
one thing you got to remember is that
anytime you ask for anything you are
warming up the earth a little bit
so just remember that you know like just
just remember these are really big gpus
that are going juice juice juice so
you know use it wisely
and your wallet also would appreciate it
yes yeah but uh definitely check those
things out um the stuff that we've been
talking about is like textual inversion
um
yes dream booth uh
fine tuning models that's where you can
start like adding characters adding
people to these models that didn't
already exist in them
uh it's worth exploring if you're an
artist you can load in all your work and
and what's amazing is that
the number one question i get asked by
artists is when i load in all of my
pictures
will then everybody be able to like use
my style and the answer is no right the
answer is like when you do this training
on your own uh computer or whatever
maybe or you can use google collab and
and things where you can you know pay a
small monthly fee
to to do the training with their stuff
you know um
you will be the only person that has
that file right and unless you share
that file that training then you're
you're fine yep
i will say
if you relied on many other people to
teach you yes relied on many other
people to share their projects in their
code right if you give nothing back
that's arguably selfish and arguably it
is it's selfish it's selfish it's 100
selfish if you learn from the openness
of others be open yourself and share it
that's
that's how we even got here in the first
place so
yeah check that stuff out to be human is
to share to be human is to share do
computers share we don't know what is it
what is it what is it to be human i
don't know two areas to be human
to forgive is to be divine yeah uh to
err is human
forgive to forgive is is yeah something
like that yeah you're right so if you do
it if you don't
forget whatever will be divine
yes oh my god that was so good that was
so good
if you had only said it in the same
voice that would have been true yeah
well i can't replicate that well i can
replicate his voice so i make an ai
model of it first so we haven't seen it
yet you have plenty of plenty of it
right you can generate them yeah
yeah or actually
there's a service that's this close like
just give us like two minutes of
somebody's voice and we'll duplicate it
for you
yeah right
already
already exists
yeah oh boy well man i'm really excited
to mess around with the uh model fine
tuning this battery requires 38
gigabytes of vram uh for now yeah it
means
i have to take one of the computers the
guys are using on son of a
dungeon need to make cool pictures of me
you can rent those computers right don't
you rent those
yeah no
yeah you can rent them you can rent them
yeah
no like like online rentals oh right
right i mean if somebody else wants oh
yeah i mean if you don't have a nice
computer you can look at like doing
collab or computer run pod is one where
you know literally you have like a
computer on on your desktop and on those
like pretty solid gpus that they're
running on a100s
right now you can get multiple a100 i
don't know how to use multiple a100s but
you can get multiple yeah it's like a
dollar and change every hour that's
really not that bad
for uh
how much cost it's worth mentioning a100
is like the best gpu you can get right
now what is a gpu gpu graphics
processing unit oh but i'm not doing
graphics we're doing ai well that's
because what's on a gpu is really just
meant to crunch math it's not meant to
run scripts which is like what a cpu is
meant for it's meant to just crunch math
right and just so happens that machine
learning models
under the hood
is just millions and millions of very
basic multiplications that are happening
so
gpu can do that uh very fast and i think
it's a better use than trying to just do
fake math to let somebody pay for their
drugs on silk road
you know that's true i think it's a
better use is to to make homer simpson
in
in the style of hyaluronic what if you
take homer simpson and you put him into
dragon ball z and then you turn that
into an nft
so that way you're hitting both worlds
at the same time
we're doomed as a society as human
beings we're going to have to have
ai can take over as the brain well once
we're all solar and like fusion powered
and like energy is free again yeah yeah
that'll be fine yeah yeah yeah
all right
oh no no we got others here yeah coming
in yeah
so anyways in a few weeks uh
i'm jumping in here yes please
technically that microphone over there
is the one
christian's gotta go
i was just coming to say hi
i was just coming to say hi
hey i'll do the outro for you guys hey
dude it's been a while man
yeah hello hello and goodbye everyone
three two one ah
oh god i don't know which one is working
all right i'm giving you a real outro
all right
everybody this world is moving really
fast right now
like the tools have changed so fast
literally every day something new is
coming out that is
totally changing our workflow around
this
super exciting let's all stay on this
ride together uh joe thank you so much
for joining us thank you for having me
jeez you just showed up on nowhere yeah
no i'm i'm very much so looking forward
to listening to this podcast uh yeah
what do you think it's about fringes of
all of this stuff right now
i'm not in your guy's private discord
server but i get like rumors of it all
the time you need an application yeah
christian you gotta join us too
oh my god dude that's just a drawing of
nico perringer
in the style of somebody who does not
like ai on purpose we did it like that
but wait did it is there any like image
image going on here or is it just like
just new yeah it's new i taught it
yeah i taught it oh you taught okay okay
so there's some training okay i taught
it
i taught it to do that it's like it just
sounds like a proud dad yeah anyways
this is great joe thank you so much for
visiting us everybody thank you so much
for listening uh we're going to be doing
a probably a stable diffusion based
experiment video for the quarter crew
channel on friday oh uh it'll obviously
come out like a week or so after we make
it um
are you going to force me to drive all
the way back to downward light again i
live in santa barbara you live in santa
barbara really i drove two and a half
hours for this podcast because no you
didn't did you and that was two hours
wow yeah but i'm excited about talking
about this stuff i'm excited to see my
buddies i took a covert test before i
came
and you're positive
thanks for coming
it will be a podcast for a while
probably
we already had it like a few weeks ago
all right thanks for listening everybody
we'll see you in another one uh maybe
the next one we'll just talk about like
i don't know like legos or pup puppies
puppies in florida probably he's in
florida
florida yep you'll get it when you
listen to the podcast run okay i'm
excited everybody